شكرا لناديم الان فعلا الى منصات التواصل
ونبداها من فلسطين ودول العربيه ايضا حيث
اطلق ناشطون فلسطينيون حمله الكترونيه
باسم اوقفوا هدم القدس رفضا لسياسته
وقرارات الاحتلال بهدم بيوت ومنشات
للمقدسيين وحذروا من تداعياتها من الصوت
مقدسيه قالت انها رصدت 30 حاله هدم لي
منازل ومنشات الفلسطينيين في القدس منذ
بدايه الشهر الحالي فقط تفاعل رواد
المنصات من الصلاه التواصل مع هذه الحمله
ونبدا بسند بذياب الذي يقول هناك كارثه
حقيقيه ترتكب بحق اهل القدس من هدم منازل
واعتقالات والتضييق واغلاقات يوميه يجب
على الجميع مستندتهم والوقوف معهم في كل
الوسائل المتاحه قبل فوات الاوان مع عماد
ابو الروس فكتب يقول
مجزره هدم تجري في القدس من السلطات
الاحتلال تتزايد عمليه التهويد يوما بعد
يوم اوقفوا هد ما القدس ايضا كتب وسام
حموده جريمه حرب فاشيه شبحو الهدم يطارد
المقدسيين اوقفوا هدم القدس